clic clic waouh tu fais hyper bien le
clic merci à toi
salut romain saint romain romain est là
non il est pas là non vous inquiétez pas
tout va bien je vais vous expliquer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette année ça fait quatre ans que
détesté existe enfin ça fera quatre ans
en avril pour être possible pendant ces
quatre ans j'ai créé différents formats
alors parfois avec des invités parfois à
l'extérieur mais quand même le plus
souvent tout seul avec romain derrière
la caméra
évidemment et bien cette année on va
tenter un truc nouveau et vous allez
pouvoir participer ce truc nouveau c'est
un live sur la santé évidemment qui va
s'appeler docteur good et que je vais
animer avec deux collègues mardin
l'orphelin internes en médecine
influenceurs et ancienne miss france
vous l'avez sûrement koné et michel
cymes médecin et animateur télé mais
vous l'avez sur leur commune aussi tous
les trois on va choisir une thématique
sur la santé et on va en discuter
ensemble et avec vous pendant une heure
l'idée c'est de faire quelque chose de
positif pour vous aider à bien vous
sentirez à bien vous portez vous
connaissez et surtout de vous donner des
bons conseils pour rester en bonne santé
tout ça en étant en contact avec vous je
vous explique comment ça va se passer
marine et moi on va préparer des sujets
précis sur la thématique de l'émission
michel lui évidemment le thème de
l'émission il le connaît mais il sait
pas de quoi on va parler dont une fois
qu'on a fini de présenter nos sujets on
va en discuter tous ensemble on va
développer et surtout on va répondre à
vos questions
le coeur de l'émission c'est ça c'est
d'échanger avec vous donc soyez pas
timides
vous venez vous posez vos questions
évidemment ce sera anonyme
juste pour être très clair on va
répondre à vos questions générales sur
le sujet on va pas faire de
consultations individuelles
ça c'est pas possible alors concrètement
comment ça va se passer et où ça va se
passer
eh ben ça va se passer sur le live alors
le live c'est quoi le live c'est une
chaîne c'est des émissions qui vont
avoir lieu tous les jours en live
d'où le nom de 17 heures à minuit avec
des créatrices des créateurs de vidéos
des animatrices des animateurs et plein
de gens que vous connaissez bien sur
plein de sujets hyper différent
d'ailleurs en réalité le live ça a déjà
commencé ça a commencé le 3 février pour
être précis et vous pouvez retrouver ça
partout mais genre partout sur toutes
les plateformes vidéo et sur
l'application dédiée
et donc docteur boudent notre émission
ce sera un bimensuel alors bimensuel ça
veut dire tous les quinze jours
deux fois par mois pour être très clair
un mercredi sur deux de 20h à 21h alors
vous allez me dire ok mais ça va pas se
passer sur dtc du coup je vais vous
répondre oui et non parce que le live
évidemment ça va être sur le live mais
je vous mettrai tous les quinze jours
sur détester les vidéos que j'ai tourné
pour l'émission et qui sont bien dans
l'esprit de la chaîne hbo d'ailleurs
pour vous faire une petite idée de ce à
quoi ça va ressembler j'ai un cadeau
pour vous vous pouvez regarder la vidéo
que j'ai tourné pour le pilote de
l'émission donc qui sera pas diffusé en
cliquant là quelque part je sais jamais
où ça du coup je vais vous remettre
aussi le lien dans la description de la
vidéo soit plus c'est une vidéo qui
s'appelle 7 trucs à savoir sur votre
cerveau je vous invite à aller la
regarder et je vous invite à me dire
dans les commentaires ce que vous en
pensez
évidemment et je vous invite surtout à
venir voir dr wood sur le live un
mercredi sur deux de 20h à 21h et ça va
commencer
ben là tout de suite en fait ça va
commencer dans deux heures à partir du
moment où je mets cette vidéo en ligne
je vous mets toutes les informations
nécessaires dans la description de la
vidéo et je vous donnerai aussi des
nouvelles assez régulièrement sur mes
réseaux sociaux donc n'hésitez pas à
vous abonner voit la dtcc fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite sur
le live avec dr wood est sûre dtc pour
de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez soin
de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien